das hat sich immer weiter gesteigert das
zum schluss denn so schlimm war dass ich
dann früh kommen könnte und alkohol
wurde dann der führerschein wir gehen
dann schaltet dann die frau von lothar
ist harte arbeit verloren aber das war
alles noch mehr zeit vertreten
juni wenn ich rein
zu meinem eigenen schutz weil ich habe
bestimmt gehört
psychische probleme
schicksalsschläge suchterkrankungen
erwachsene menschen mit
unterschiedlichen geschichten die doch
11 allein kommen sie im alltag nicht
zurecht sie brauchen hilfe dank eines
projekts der aktion wandlungs welten
jena müssen sie nicht in heim oder
kliniken leben sondern werden nochmal
teil einer familie wie bei den heynckes
toni ist hier eigentlich nur gast doch
das inzwischen seit zehn jahren
mittlerweile fühlt sich seinen eltern
spricht probleme zu sagen die leute sind
fallen da wenn man tiefpunkt auch
höhepunkte werden geteilt
die gegenseite ist aufeinander eingehen
emotional ist das viel dass man
versucht die dinge mit sicher ist zu
machen aber doch nicht wenn man nicht
weiterkommt dann leute zu haben wo wir
jetzt mal kein hingehen wohin es nicht
schämen zu müssen einfach auch mal
beiden sie dürfen wenn man traurig ist
ja einfach mal zeigen sind dort wie
immer ist das ist ein schönes gefühl
also es gibt auch sie scheidet und
gefühl von zuhause zu sein von man auf
angekommen zu sein für ihren gast
bekommen die heynckes rund 900 euro
monatlich knapp die hälfte zahlt das
sozialamt für die andere hälfte kommt
toni selbst auf dafür hat er hier auch
einen eigenen bereich in den er sich
auch mal zurückziehen kann
doch der weg bis hierhin war lang 17
jahre ist es inzwischen her als toni
einen kalten entzug machte das erste mal
das trikot habe stadt nichts mehr
getrunken ich bin dann waren die ängste
da alleine zu sterben angst ja ich habe
keine luft mehr bekommen ich bin ich
nach aus einkaufen gegangen bin wie die
klinik als am anfang war das ganz
schwierig da was alle vierteljahre
bestimmt drei wochen in der klinik in
dieser zeit häuft toni tausende euro
schulden an muss in die privatinsolvenz
er bekommt eine gesetzliche betreuerin
dann hat sich halt die aktion wandlungs
welten 2010 dann vorgestellt und hat
gesagt das ist das programm hätten
könnten wir noch überhaupt nichts
darunter vorstellen wie es ist einfach
bei fremden die tür aufzumachen sagen
hallo hier bin ich schläft mehr
ließ dann mal auch mal in der woche
proben denn da war haben wir uns
kennengelernt in allem gesehen das
stimmt also ich war bereit
stehenden zu öffnen die arbeit mir zu
helfen über die jahre bei den heynckes
hat sich sein zustand zwar stabilisiert
geblieben sind aber seine angstzustände
und depressionen immer wieder ausgelöst
durch berufliche oder private
rückschläge zu seinen beiden kindern hat
der 49 jährige nur selten kontakt beim
anblick von bildern aus vergangenen
tagen über man ihn seine gefühle
sehnsucht
aber auch traurigkeit und
irgendwie auch wieder
wieder sonne auf versagt zu haben als
vater
hätte sicherlich vieles anders machen
können
im nachhinein wahrscheinlicher machen
wollen war es war also mit zu dem
zeitpunkt wie so und jetzt ist es an der
zeit
dass
wieder in die richtigen bahnen zu leiten
auch mal vielleicht entschuldigen zu
sagen denn gegen gegenübers
alle zwei wochen bekommen sie besuch von
ihrer betreuerin christina pommer hallo
bei den treffen erkundigt sie sich wie
es läuft probleme werden besprochen arzt
termine abgestimmt
[Musik]
haben ebenfalls ebenso als
risikopatient das klar start nochmal die
heynckes unterstützen wo sie können nur
dank menschen wie ihnen ist das projekt
der aktion wandlungs welten überhaupt
möglich
habe in der zeitung gelesen dass
gastfamilien gesucht werden bei
wandlungsfähigen habe ich zufällig die
anderen sehr gelesen und wir hatten
platz und ich finde so ein mensch noch
zusätzlich in der familie das ist auch
eine bereicherung für uns selber und für
den menschen sicher auch toni hatte
glück dass für ihn eine familie gefunden
wurde
wir haben ganz ganz ganz viele anfragen
von menschen die in unterstützungsbedarf
haben und daher sind wir immer ganz nah
auf der suche nach gastfamilien die
sich bereiterklären menschen zu
unterstützen deshalb steht die
öffentlichkeitsarbeit an erster stelle
in der zentrale der aktion wandlungs
welten in jena koordinieren sie das
projekt betreutes wohnen in familien
seit 2006 sind wir eine so genannte
ambulante regel leistungen der
eingliederungshilfe
also das wird vom sozialamt finanziert
die gastfamilien erhalten wir eine
betreuungspauschale wir erhalten träger
kosten seit inzwischen 18 jahren
versuchen sie erwachsenen mit seelischen
oder geistigen beeinträchtigungen im
alltag einen halt zu geben und die
anfragen häufen sich prima dann schreibe
ich mir das ein und dann sehen wir uns
nächste woche am mittwoch um 13 uhr bis
dahin tschüss
aktuell haben wir tatsächlich so zwei
bis drei anfragen von potentiellen gast
bewohnern in der woche die müssen wir
natürlich auch erst mal kennen lernen
also da müssen wir dann zu zweit gucken
und hinfahren denjenigen kennenlernen
gucken wo ist der unterstützungsbedarf
einmal pro woche berät sich ihr team
gemeinsam überlegen und entscheiden sie
welcher gast zu welcher familie passen
könnte
da haben wir sehr
intensive anfangsphase
also es gibt es kennenlernen mit einem
bewohner und der familie dann gibt es
probewohnen über ein wochenende oder
über zwei drei tage und dann nochmal ein
probewohnen über 14 tage und erst danach
können sich alle parteien entscheiden da
die hälfte ihres sechsköpfigen teams
gerade auf hausbesuch ist tauschen sie
sich heute nur in kleiner runde aus
genug zu klären gibt es immer
wenn es konfliktsituation in der familie
mit einen bewohner gibt dann besprechen
wir das erstmal natürlich mit der
familie und den bewohner gucken ob wir
den konflikt vielleicht im haus besuch
schon lösen können und dann ist es aber
auch immer ganz schön in der runde hier
mit den kollegen auch noch mal zu
überlegen was gibt es für möglichkeiten
oder für ideen auch da
konfliktsituationen zu bearbeiten
verstreut in ganz thüringen betreuen sie
aktuell 40 gast bewohnerinnen und
bewohner in familien die jeweils immer
vom selben sozialarbeiter besucht werden
das wieder eingliederungshilfe also das
bedeutet eigentlich dass diejenigen über
einen gewissen zeitraum meiner familie
leben und dann auch wieder
eigenständig leben können
doch ganz oft ist es so dass der
hilfebedarf weiter besteht und menschen
länger bei einer familie bleiben so ist
das auch bei mohn sie hat eine
intelligenzminderung und eine borderline
persönlichkeitsstörung sei siebeneinhalb
jahren lebt sie nun bei den knappen hier
fühlt sie sich wohl auch wegen der
vielen tiere
meine hauptsächlichen aufgaben sind
eigentlich mich um meine katzen zum
kummer die abends reinzuholen zu füttern
die natur zu zumachen oder mittagszeit
auch fördern und die abnahme der umgang
mit den tieren beruhigt sie hilft ihr
runter zu fahren
weil wenn es mir nicht so gut geht geht
zum türmen oder die katzen merken dass
oder die runde machen das aus sofort
oder geld wenn es große schwierigkeiten
ist gehe ich zur route oder
vor moni hatte ute clubhits bereits
mehrere pflegekinder aufgenommen und
großgezogen neben den eigenen kindern zu
mancher zeit war das haus voll erzählt
sie
geworden ich bin erzählerin von beruf
naja das hat sich einfach so angetan es
hat sich so entwickelt magic software
die auf arbeit irgendwie moni arbeitet
in einer behindertenwerkstatt neben den
aufgaben hier zuhause verleiht die
beschäftigung dort ihrem tag struktur
dieser alltag brach jedoch weg als sie
wegen corona monate lang nicht arbeiten
gehen durfte die 32 jährige fiel in ein
tiefes loch
eingeschlichen so ein bisschen länger
schlafen nicht nur ein bisschen und
ich musste dann feststellen
tabletten nicht mehr so regelmäßig
genommen hat hat sie dann aber selber
auch für sich gesagt mensch ich muss
jetzt hier was ändern und hat dann auch
gesagt sie geht in die klinik das ist
dann auch so eine krisenintervention
nennt man das wo sie dreieinhalb wochen
in der klinik war und wurde dort dann
auch auf die medikamente wieder
eingestellt moni selbst geht ganz offen
mit ihrer krankheit um
zu meinem eigenen schutz weil ich habe
bestimmt gehört dass ich mich selbst
verletzen soll und umfang soll und da
bin ich zu meinem eigenen schutz rain
zuvor musst du sie jahrelang kein
einziges mal mehr zurück in die
psychiatrie
wer hat jetzt wieder versuchen so stabil
zu werden
[Musik]
es können kann immer wieder mal
vorkommen also die bewohner können
natürlich in die krise rutschen sind
kann über einen langen zeitraum stabil
sein rutschten dann aber auch mal eine
krise aus was für gründen auch immer und
das begleiten wir dann auch ganz
zurzeit geht es mir besser auch weil sie
inzwischen wieder regelmäßig arbeiten
gehen kann das und die geborgenheit hier
in der familie geben hier einen halt den
sie früher nicht hatte
[Musik]
hier bei den klubs hat sie feste
bezugspersonen die ihr den rücken
stärken und immer für sie da sind wenn
sie
alles was sie in ihrer kindheit nie
kennengelernt hat und jetzt nicht mehr
missen möchte
[Musik]
und das muss sie auch nicht wenn es nach
ihrer gastmutter geht's ich habe das
gefühl dass ich noch etwas geben kann
solange es noch geht an
die gründe sind vielfältig warum die
einen fremde bei sich aufnehmen und
andere bei fremden ein zuhause suchen
doch am ende 1 die meisten eines das aus
fremden freunde werden oder gar familie